Mr robertland he was the former Justice
secretary with us now hello to you sir
Robert thanks for joining us on the
program this morning
um thoughts on these flurry of
resignations so far this morning it's
only 20 past seven yes and I I think you
know if the writing wasn't on the wall
last night I'm afraid it's very clearly
written on the wall this morning and the
Prime Minister I think has no choice but
to leave office uh he now needs to think
about the good not just of the party but
actually of the country and you know to
quote him back about him not wanting
politicians to talk about themselves
well now it seems to me the best way to
do that is for him to go and for us to
get back to the priorities of the people
of our country whether it's cost of
living the threat of war in Europe and
Dewar in Europe and all those
international issues that are having an
effect here at home
perhaps you can help Tamara and I out
with that question that we were opposing
to each other which was all these people
having resigned even if the Prime
Minister does go or is forced to go with
a vote of no confidence perhaps as early
as next Tuesday because of the 1922
committee rule changes potentially on
these potentials
um will those people then be asked to go
back into post until we've got a new
leader given that if they don't we don't
have a functioning government and the
Prime Minister could still be in number
10 until the autumn
well a very good point Kay I think I
think we are in uncharted waters I think
what's crucial is that we have enough uh
people uh carrying out the functions of
government it would be like a sort of
caretaker period where there wouldn't be
new policy initiatives but there's
plenty frankly for the government to be
getting on with uh you know I I didn't
think this prime minister had a problem
and it turned in terms of the number of
initiatives that he's already announced
it's it's how to deliver them that
really matters and therefore what we
need is is the minimum necessary to do
that and of course it's for the
conservative party to get on with the
job of quickly selecting a success I
think the Parliamentary votes could be
held before the end of this term and
then if there needs to be a membership
ballot that could be done in August so
we could have a new leader in September
so we might only be talking about a
period of a few of six weeks or so
um but but you know I think it's
important that the British constitution
is an Unwritten thinker it's a thing of
beauty and wonder but it's not written
down anywhere and it does depend on all
of us to be good team players and to
respect convention not to bring the
queen into any controversy to to be good
team players prime minister's got an
opportunity to do that and to show at
the end of his Premiership that respect
for the Constitution and for our system
of government that uh um
I know I'm so sorry we're just hearing
that the science Minister George Freeman
has also just stepped down so he has
just announced that he cannot work with
the Prime Minister and he has also
stepped down that's 50 MPS 50 members of
government now on the government payroll
have stepped down this is not what's he
going to do what this is not normal as
you say uh and through their
resignations and colleagues like George
and other sort of all friends and
colleagues of mine are expressing uh
publicly what I and others have been
saying now for the last 24 hours hours
or so it's increasingly obvious that I'm
afraid because of because of Personality
issues because of the lack of trust that
now exists that the Prime Minister
cannot go on I'm desperately sad about
UK we came into office on a one nation
ticket you know I believe in one nation
conservatism to my bones and I wanted
this prime minister to bring the country
together we dealt with covid we we we
had an unprecedented challenge these
were huge and serious challenges and
he's capable he's been capable of so
much but no longer we need fresh
leadership and we need a a a a better
leadership in order to deal with the
huge challenges that our country faces
yeah um he's not going anywhere though
is he and he is the prime minister you
know we have to recognize the Office of
Prime Minister we have to give it due
respect but he has said that uh in order
to get rid of me you'll have to bathe
your hands in blood I think that's the
Shakespearean reference he's just not
gonna go unless he's forced to well okay
you've put it very well if I may say so
respect for the office of prime minister
but you know that includes the incumbent
the incumbent has to respect the office
that they hold and I can't think of any
greater respect for that office than by
honoring constitutional Norms by
accepting the verdict of the party that
he now needs to go not not just for the
good of the party but for the good of
our country we we are better than this
he is better than this I think at the
end of it and I hope he's asking himself
this morning really can I now go on with
so few uh colleagues supporting me and I
think you'll find the answers of
resounding no and then actually we can
deliver the agenda that I know he
believes him which is one nation
conservative government bringing our
country together rising to the challenge
of the cost of living and international
threats and being serious about the next
few years and getting the job done to
again use his famous quote
um you have been a loyal Lieutenant to
this prime minister for a very long time
I've spoken to you often and you've been
on those media rounds as we describe
them where the minister goes out to talk
to the public via the Television Studios
in the mornings
um what was the Tipping Point for you
what made you think I I can't support
him any long
well not dissimilar to many other
colleagues I I was absolutely prepared
to give our elected prime minister and
our elected leader the the benefit of
the dope when it came to some of the
issues relating sadly to parties uh and
to other issues where sadly the truth
seems to have been different from the
original version of events but you know
there's a cumulative effect of this and
I've always felt okay that at some point
there would be a last straw moment and I
think I'm afraid in the obfuscation and
excuse making that we've seen in the
last few days surrounding his former
deputy chief whip it became increasingly
clear to me that colleagues were being
sent out to say things that just weren't
true and you cannot run a government on
that basis the British people expect
straightforwardness integrity and
honesty from our leaders sometimes
things go wrong and when things go wrong
you need to be able to explain that to
man up and explain it and and I I saw an
absence of that this week and it's with
huge sadness that I've concluded that
this prime minister can no longer go on
well we're just hearing from number 10
they're saying that he's going to carry
on with his reshuffle this morning that
needs to go ahead of course because of
uh the changes that we've seen over the
last couple of days
um just reading from George Freeman's a
letter if you'll indulge me please Sir
Robert I wondered if you could comment
on this I'm afraid the culmination of
your lack of transparency and Candor
with Parliament and willingness to ask
your ministers to mislead Parliament
your removal of key pillars of the
ministerial code your handling of your
appointment of a deputy chief whip who
it turns out you knew had a history of
sexual abuse allegations is just too
much this is seriously damaging public
trust and respect for government
democracy and the law and this great
party is long Tradition at the party of
Standards character conduct integrity
and duty to office and Country before
partisan
self-interest and still he goes on with
a reshuffle very strong words from
George Freeman I I don't disagree with
any of them the conservative party is
about respect for our constitution our
rule of law Margaret Thatcher talked
about Freedom under the law uh it's
something that I believe in to my heart
and I think every conservative does
believes the same and therefore when you
have uh somebody who seems to think that
their idea of the Premiership is them in
it I'm afraid that's not good enough uh
we as conservatives as people who are
stewards of our of our country and our
government should expect and demand more
from our leaders and that's why there's
one word I'm afraid that he needs to
listen to which is go
I was flabbergasted yesterday when I was
watching the Telly at home and I heard
that the senior cabinet had gone in to
see him and the chief whip was there
figuratively with the whiskey and the
revolver and still he said no I'm going
nowhere did you think the game was up
last night
well I I thought the game was up much
earlier in the day and um frankly uh the
one person in whose hands this could
have been dealt with is is the prime
minister this could have been so
different if there was a a proper
application to the issues at hand a real
focus on uh some of the question marks
and challenges about the way he does
things the way he runs government it was
up to him to make those changes to
accept that we can all do better you
know self-improvement is something I
again very much believe and we can
always do better we can always improve
and I I think that lack of
self-awareness almost and and a sort of
a doggy belief that uh you know it
doesn't matter how you get there we will
muddle through I'm afraid just isn't
good enough the joke's over now and it's
time to leave office
Nadeem zahawi are the new chance that I
spoke to him yesterday on the program
and he insisted that the Prime Minister
had Integrity do you think he does
well I'm afraid he's displaying uh that
that he no longer has that and you know
it's with huge sadness that I say that
because I I think that there are so many
qualities about Royce Johnson I've known
him for many years and I've admired a
lot of what he has done you know through
covid through brexit we got things done
and we got a lot done uh under his
leadership and there are many many good
things he'll be able to point to but you
know the manner of uh one's leaving is
also very important and it's how
somebody will be judged and if if a
leader leaves with good grace observing
constitutional norms and accepting that
however a high uh he or she might have
come they only serve at the pleasure of
the British people and indeed their
party then I think he will be able to
emerge with at least some of his
reputation intact at the moment he's
single-handedly shredding that uh
through every utterance we hear from
number 10 this morning this is now an
unreal situation to talk about
reshuffling in the day who's gonna who's
gonna accept office uh it it is just
she's just absurd and we need to to end
this end this fast now
I want it you've read my mind I I wanted
to ask you sir Robert how he will
because we are entering the end game
however you look at it the Prime
Minister
um is done uh how do you think he will
be remembered will he be the Prime
Minister who just wouldn't leave office
until he was dragged out kicking and
screaming or will he be the Prime
Minister who got brexit done
well look again it's in his hands I
think that he wants to be remembered as
the Prime Minister who got brexit done
and who stewarded us through the most
unprecedented peacetime challenge in our
history the covid crisis uh three
tumultuous years it's not about length
of time so it's about what you did in
office and he'll be able to appoint to a
lot of achievements I was honored to
serve as his Lord Chancellor getting
important criminal justice reforms done
and we've we've achieved huge change to
sentencing uh in our country which I
believe will make us safer lots of
things he'll be able to point to with
pride but now is the time to uh uh exit
the stage and to accept that with great
sadness his Premiership is over